oh my bit of a late start here okay here
we go welcome to this video playing
harry potter that guy um killed me in an
earlier game with some sideline of the
Roy let's see what we get here array
Reggie opening usually something that
like quite a lot it's not that wide it's
my and white is much better here but
it's some position that I normally play
quite well and white gets that central
on that extra center pron here so what
is he going for 95 or we can t 1
huh interesting
ninety-four sorts and move them move
orders not quite clear to me
and on 95 I can also play Knight to f5
okay the ship before I also like to
prevent their going with an f3 based set
up here 25 where are you going here
don't don't cry to get it the ones
possible what is he doing here
yeah even F for now is interesting or
does he have some weird tactic ok now
it's got 95 in that case let's be
cautious e a bit
a very nice center but he's got some
pressure and I lost that earlier game
which made me a bit very about the sky
he um played that pretty well that
earlier game so I'm a bit on the
cautious side here and came to I just
trade stuff would really like to get in
if I've somehow maybe takes cooney 25
that then pinning business we should
bishop on h7 and thuy not see to it it
it gets you yeah it tends to make you
nervous after a while
okay where is he going there with that
night back I mean then I go 94 you can
go Bishop d3 but Queen f3 and I don't
see the point it should be good writing
oils just you have something that I
absolutely don't see yet some we
attacked a go on now just went back ya
hear you success also move e 6 why not
looks pretty good
I mean I go e7 if he is not taking so I
guess he has to take it check ok yeah
Bishop c6 or Queens e6b to us hanging
hmm b2 is hanging that's not good that's
something better than taking stuff
probably not so let's let's take
material and the time situation is not
so great related but can I take d7
then-rookie a tour f Bishop c5 coming up
I think I can do that
can use that momentum that a tempo
currently its material is equal i can
take b5 so let's check now i can take be
5 or i can do stuff like now let's take
them take the porn ask things written or
worried about other things later so i
can take everything on a fate now and
take 87 yeah okay let's do that and do
it quickly right back the Knights form a
barrier for the king if I hope at least
for the time being until my king is is
approaching
I could go night d44 9604 so now that
that's Jack that's helpful black resigns
okay I got a revenge winnin against him
yeah I like that kind of position I
think white is usually a little bit
better with them with the extra porn of
the extra point is wrong but that's porn
in the center even though that pressure
here is a bit bit of an issue sometimes
okay so i think i'd hope I kept kept
good control down this position looks
good yeah and to the engine thinks that
are quite a bit better here and here and
end up play the engine moves that's good
something else here between b3 queen bee
three is an interesting why not this is
there some Melanie five okay yeah just
clearing even though I'm not quite
positive why this plus two what the
engine is giving and unique ok Knight
takes Queen B seven is pretty awful yeah
this is also pretty awful now okay it's
a bad position so that would have been
even better even though that mix I mean
this is also not not bad and he be five
is a mistake i guess now after that it
gets quite serious and wide win see a 94
also good but why it has a very
substantial advantage I interesting
before is given as a better defense now
it's not very human button interest
check something like that could have
happened when three against two with
three minor pieces it's very uncommon
material balance our material
distribution I have no idea it should
probably be a draw would never ever do
get this kind of thing and that is a
winning endgame but i think i did did
well enough until he blundered that
their bishop okay well thanks for
watching